- This is my first question,
'cause I know that you
were raised by single mom
that was a teacher as well.
- Yes.
- Me as well.
- My mom taught public
school 5th/6th grade.
She's retired now
- Yeah.
- The last couple of years,
but she wants to see her grandkids more.
But yeah,
- Yeah
- She taught public school.
- Yeah, mine did too.
And when you went to public school,
nobody ever did that for me.
Like Shannon did, like her teacher.
Did you ever have anything
like that kind of assignment?
- No, no, not really. I
mean I knew because that
was my mother's reason for why I couldn't,
y'know, "can we get the Star Trek toy?"
"No, we can't afford it."
It was always we can't afford it.
- We were broke too.
- So I just thought like,
"we must be so poor!"
Y'know? (laughs)
- Yeah. (laughs)
Because, y'know, she definitely did um,
well she did have one lesson
that she kind of tried to
impart to me, growing up.
Well I really wanted a
dog, when I was a kid.
- Oh yeah, every kid.
- It was a lil' little house in Boston.
Y'know, in they lil' block,
and it was pretty normal,
near a park, whatever.
And my mom said,
"You're not responsible
enough to have a dog."
I was 10, I was like,
"I am responsible enough!"
She said, "You're right.
Why don't you show me
that you can do this?
You have to walk the dog
everyday, twice a day."
I said, "Well okay, let's get the dog!"
And she goes,
"No. First, you have to
walk an imaginary dog."
(crowd laughs)
- I was like, "Twice? What did you say?"
"Twice a day, around the
block, as if you had the dog.
So that I know that you will do it,
and you're responsible enough to do it."
So this woman, who I hope is watching,
- I hope so too!
- Gave me a leash!
And I had to walk around the
block with an empty leash.
- [Kelly] You look nuts!
- And worse!
We get to three weeks in, and she's like,
- [Kelly] (gasps) No!
"All right, forget it,
I'm not giving you a dog."
(crowd gasps)
- No!
- Yeah, so she taught me the
lesson of disappointment.
- [Kelly] Ah, yeah. I was like, what?!
That's like all your
hard work for nothing.
That is not a good lesson.
- I know.
- Once she realized, she was like,
"I didn't think you were
gunna fall through."
- Oh my God, so you never got the dog.
- Well I, yeah I didn't get a dog.
And then I thought I was so deprived,
I did like the dumbest thing you can do.
Which you can, that's the kind of thing
you tend to do when you're
18, which is how old I was.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I, soon as I moved to
LA and decided to be an actor,
and had no money and no job.
I lived in a tiny apartment like on, um,
Cherokee and Yucca,
over there in Hollywood.
Like, I was like, "I'm
getting a dog." (laughs)
(crowd laughs)
- [Kelly] Dammit
- So, I went out and got a dog.
Not only get a dog, but I got a husky.
(crowd wow's)
- Which is like, the most,
y'know have anyone had one?
- That's a hyper dog.
- They only roam.
They only want to escape.
Y'know what I mean?
That's there, like, mission in life.
- Yeah.
- But then I quickly realized like,
"Oh, you have to get the dog food."
(laughter)
- And then like,
the vet costs money.
- [Kelly] I have to feed it.
- All of a sudden, I'm kinda
going broke on this dog.
Ah, has a sad ending to the story though,
which was that um, I used to leave the dog
in a little space, shared space,
in the apartment when I went out.
So he'd have some outdoor
time, and dog got stolen.
- That's wrong!
- This was before the little,
the microchips and the
stuff you could put in it.
Y'know you could track 'em down,
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- and yeah so somebody stole the dog.
But, it's telling that I didn't rush out
and get another dog.
- Yeah, right.
You were like, "You know
what, the universe knew."
- Whoa, yeah.
Somebody has spoken and this is probably,
he probably was not living
his best life with me.
- [Kelly] I did the same thing.
- I'm sure he has a very
happy life, on a farm,
in Montana somewhere.
- I did the same thing though.
When I was young, I was like;
I think you, when you're out here,
'cause I moved out here too
and you want companionship
or some kind of,
you can't be lonely.
So I did that too.
It was a dumb move.
- Yeah, and it's like,
- [Kelly] I ended up having a
friend take care of the dog.
- When you have the least
money, the smallest place.
- [Kelly] You make the poorest decisions.
- And you're the dumbest!
Well like, let me find another
life that could depend on me.
- 'Cause I'm holding it
down solidly like myself.
- [Ben Affleck] (laughing)
Because I have it taken care of.